c'est vrai c'est un espoir
les graines la mémoire du règne végétal
les conserver les trier et les
commercialiser c'était un métier à
l'époque celui de grains entiers
c'est impressionnant comme un tiroir
1094 des graines bien au delà de
l'aspect pratique le grainetier était
aussi un collectionneur une graine de
musa qu'est ce que c'est ça nous
chagrine du bananier
mais au fil du temps le métier a disparu
ou plutôt il s'est industrialisée dans
les années 80 concurrencée par les
magasins les graines qui ont déserté les
marchés ont maintenant moi je m'arrête
citons la retraite je m'arrête quoi et
vous n'avez personne qui va reprendre
garcia marquez reprend conséquences de
l'amour du métier des variétés de fruits
et légumes ont disparu du commerce au
profit d'autres plus robuste mais
surtout plus standardisés pour trouver
des espèces diversifié reste le troc de
graines pratique entre jardiniers
amateurs et des associations militantes
comme terre de semence notre combat en
ce moment c'est de reproposer aux
jardiniers en france et en europe des
variétés qu'ils soient des variétés et
pleine de saveurs plein de couleurs chez
terre de semence devenu kokopelli en
2000 qu'il y à bien plus de variété que
celles vendues dans le commerce
nous avons 1500 références dont 300
variétés de tomates on a 80 variétés de
courges une cinquantaine de l'écu
certaines d'entre elles sont ancestrales
à tel point qu'elles n'ont jamais été
répertorié dans le catalogue officiel
des variétés
pas d'existence juridique donc et c'est
sur ce point que les industriels ont
attaqué au cope et une réglementation
qui s'applique à tous que ce soit des
sociétés grande ou que ce soit des
sociétés petites que les clients soient
les clients professionnels les clients
amateurs
chacune des sociétés sur le marché doit
respecter la réglementation en 2008
kokopelli est condamné à dix-sept mille
euros damende pour concurrence déloyale
de grands groupes comme monsanto veulent
s'accaparer le marché
mais des associations continuent à
propager leurs graines c est un combat
est un acte citoyen et une désobéissance
citoyenne un modèle plus large de
société qui ne convient
de l'agriculture extensive qui nous
parle de gm qui nous parle d'engrais de
pesticides et alors que en fait tout le
monde veulent inverse en 2018 la loi
alimentation prévoyait d'ouvrir le
commerce de graines non inscrites au
catalogue des variétés avant que le
conseil constitutionnel ne censure cet
article la vente de ces semences reste
donc un geste militant
[Musique]